speaking of another one of your girls
simone is making her debut at wwe now
are you a proud papa because she's
carrying on the legacy fourth generation
she's making it for her she's made
history very very proud of her she is
fiercely
independent it's very important for her
to make her own way blaze her own trail
blaze her own path she doesn't come to
me looking for a lot which i respect
that and i'm here watching and
supporting a memory popped up on my
phone and it was you and me from the
termata truck wasn't that great in
atlanta so hot that day so hot and still
pretty hot out here
when you got married we you were engaged
then i am engaged i'm married hey
congratulations thank you and he's just
he's a man he goes tell my dj i said hey
i said hey i sure will sure okay this is
the fifth time we're seeing you and
kevin hart team up together are you
officially hollywood bff material now is
he your favorite coach this is the fifth
time and the last time that we took no i
love kevin i love kevin and we always
have the best time on screen off screen
and audiences enjoy us together too it's
also rare that you find somebody who you
have just such great chemistry with in
terms of amazing chemistry i have kevin
hart i have emily blood and when it
comes to you right and then john was in
this film john was in this krasinski was
in this too he took their girls to see
this they loved the movie
and i love the fact that you've never
lost sight of where you came from which
is wrestling last week i was in orlando
with montes ford and you sang his
praises on instagram what do you see in
him that makes them championship
material i love that guy i love his
energy i love his charisma i love his
work ethic and
you know in the world of pro wrestling
it's it's a there's nothing like the
world of pro wrestling it's very unique
and it's also a business
professional wrestling wwe it's in my
blood it's my passion i love it so for a
guy like him uh he's
he's worked his butt off like and by the
way they all do everybody in that locker
room the men the women um but him in
particular he's got um
he's got great athleticism he's got the
whole package so he's such a charming
guy he's cool yeah
he wants to see dj back in the ring
could it ever happen of course yeah i'm
always always open to that for sure
[Music]